i
[Música]
hola bienvenido a la revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
equipadas con teléfonos móviles trípodes
al hombro y computadoras portátiles un
grupo de mujeres en somalia recorre el
país en busca de historias que pretenden
crear conciencia y romper el silencio
sobre temas tabú y que afectan al género
son seis mujeres que conforman el primer
medio de comunicación feminista que
además les brinda un espacio seguro para
trabajar y elegir lo que informan en
medio de la discriminación a las mujeres
periodistas en un país altamente
conservador a continuación la historia
empezamos
en el idioma somalí vilán significa
brillante y claro y es el nombre que se
escogió para el primer medio de
comunicación de este país con enfoque de
género y conformado exclusivamente por
mujeres se trata de un proyecto dirigido
por el programa de las naciones unidas
para el desarrollo y en el que se
producen historias para varios formatos
como la televisión la radio y portales
en línea el equipo está integrado por
seis personas que vienen de distintas
partes del país africano
la editora general y cinco periodistas
que no sobrepasan los 29 años y cuentan
con experiencia en medios de
comunicación locales
y la media tiene un enfoque y una misión
en particular desafiar las normas
patriarcales mediante la producción de
noticias y reportajes que se centran en
las mujeres lo que resulta único en
somalia altamente conservadora y
predominantemente musulmana esto incluye
historias locales y temas a los que no
está acostumbrada a la audiencia somalí
como los distintos tipos de violencia de
género que a menudo son considerados
demasiado delicados en la transmisión
pública como por ejemplo delitos
sexuales un problema que va en aumento
en un país que hasta ahora no ha
aprobado su primer proyecto de ley que
criminalice estos actos sin embargo sus
integrantes consideran que tener un
equipo exclusivamente femenino ha sido
una ventaja al poder sacar a la luz
temas que todavía son un tabú y de los
cuales las mujeres no se atreven a
hablar con hombres
en milán me iría nos enfocamos en
historias que son cruciales para las
comunidades somalíes en las que vivimos
son historias de cosas que nuestra gente
ve como normales somalia
pero estas son cosas que no se
investigan adecuadamente si se
investigarán lo difundieran entonces
podríamos encontrar soluciones para el
futuro
es diferente de otras estaciones de
radio y televisión locales en milán
cubre historias sub reportadas para
crear conciencia en nuestra sociedad
comprar un cd o color good también
porque nos enfocamos en historias
relacionadas con mujeres las cuales no
son contadas adecuadamente por lo tanto
nuestras historias se publican en la
organización de medios llamada
d'alesandro salsa gravy on the sun tv y
las redes sociales de dalt sant pere de
indoor estas seis periodistas cuentan
también con un programa de formación y
tutorías con importantes nombres del
periodismo entre quienes se encuentran
prominentes figuras de cadenas como la
británica bbc o la qatarí al-jazeera
milán operada desde las oficinas de dalt
sant una importante cadena local de
radio y televisión con sede en
mogadiscio capital y según su página web
sus contenidos también se distribuyen de
forma internacional a través de medios
como the guardian la bbc y el diario el
país de españa dicen que ellas mismas
escriben guiones hacen entrevistas
editan vídeos y presentan el programa
para recoger el material noticioso solo
les basta un teléfono móvil un trípode
una libreta de apuntes o una computadora
este medio de comunicación es totalmente
diferente se estancarán nos enfocamos en
grabar vídeos usando teléfonos móviles
a medida que el mundo se desarrolla
esperamos que las cámaras ya no sean
necesarias en los próximos años en
facebook trabajaremos en nuestro
periodismo móvil filmando con nuestros
teléfonos se están volviendo más
sofisticados que lo actuado manta que
hacerse en cambio encajar pero además de
romper el silencio sobre la violencia de
género en somalia vi la media también
sienta un precedente en la manera en que
las mujeres se abren camino en el
periodismo ya que además de brindarles
un lugar seguro para trabajar cuentan
con total independencia para elegir lo
que informan y cómo
según su editora en jefe durante mucho
tiempo las mujeres periodistas somalíes
han sido tratadas como ciudadanas de
segunda clase y los medios locales han
ignorado las historias y voces de la
población el programa de las naciones
unidas para el desarrollo recogió
testimonios de periodistas que han sido
acosadas que se les niegan oportunidades
de formación y ascensos o se ignora su
autoridad cuando alcanzan puestos de
alto rango lo que también provoca que se
dejen muchos temas de lado es por esto
que vila media ha tenido una gran
acogida y genera gran expectativa en el
murcia de su aval y edad de una en
mujeres periodistas somalíes alentamos y
defendemos los derechos de las mujeres
inbox
es una gran empresa para la sociedad
especialmente para las mujeres intenta
cubrir nuestras necesidades porque da
voz a las sin voz y se enfoca en las
historias de mujeres vulnerables creo
que eso es muy importante en este
momento y es que a pesar de ser un medio
muy joven desde ya vi la medida se
prepara para su próxima generación de
mujeres periodistas pues pronto ofrecerá
pasantías para las mejores estudiantes
de último año de periodismo de dos
universidades en la capital hasta aquí
revista digital recuerde que si quieres
repetir esta u otra emisión de nuestro
programa lo puedes hacer a través de
nuestra página web www puntos francia 24
punto com
[Música]